Ariana drinks this concoction pretty
regularly and not because of the flavor
it's called kratom and it could help
fight the opioid epidemic in America I
started doing heroin when I was very
young when I was 15 I was doing it every
day and that lasted until I was 19
during someone for later relapses I only
used kratom to ease her withdrawals it
allows me to treat myself and
self-medicate responsibly and it's also
very easy to adjust your dose and come
off of it and she's not alone ariana is
one of approximately 5 million kratom
users in the u.s. fazer to treat pain
depression anxiety and in the most
extreme cases opioid addiction but
kratom is not technically an opioid it
just binds to the same neurological
receptors which is what got the DEA to
take notice
in August the agency announced plans to
emergency schedule kratom which would
have landed the drug in the same
category as heroin and LSD but a group
of tenacious users got the DEA to back
down and extend the public comment
period until December 1st with almost
30,000 people dying every year from
opioid overdoses kratom could be an
indispensable treatment so while we
could still get our hands on some we
headed down to the twisted thistle in
San Francisco to find out more but um
most basically is a tree that grows in
Southeast Asia has been used there for
hundreds of years and Ethan has no
qualms about selling this drug there are
a lot of people that have been using for
Tom for enough time where if there was
the possibility of acute overdose to the
point of death it probably would have
happened by now
the truth is science doesn't know enough
about kratom because there's very little
research on the drug but that's not to
say nobody is studying the stuff with
this is Oliver grown money today he's
about to publish a survey of kratom
users certainly I understand the DEA
that they do not want to have another
drug out there that could potentially
contribute to the already devastating
opioid epidemic that some communities
are experiencing on the other side
we also need to consider that the four
to five million estimated users of
kratom may face a health crisis of their
own if kratom becomes scheduled or
placed into schedule one and if the DEA
does schedule kratom it will get even
harder to learn about the drugs risks
and potential rewards the problem then
is that you get it stuck in schedule one
it becomes difficult to do research to
show what the actual level of risk is
and doing the studies on kratom
properties called pharmacology could
cost half a billion dollars by one
estimate whether or not Creighton
becomes a prior itself or a weapon to
fight the opioid epidemic is up to how
the DEA interprets those public comments
and even if it bans the drug some users
say they won't give it up no matter the
risk people all over continue to use
cannabis in places it's not legal so I
think I would still continue to use
Catan